[Laughter]
they're still arguing
well there's anxiety there's obsession
then there's compulsion Donald Trump
Donald Trump Trump Donald Trump Donald
Trump I think about Donald Trump Donald
Trump Donald Trump Donald Trump
we got a boot Donald Trump out of the
Oval Office Donald Trump Trump Donald
Trump Donald Trump when we're talking
about him we are losing Donald Trump
Donald Trump mr. Trump Trump Donald
Trump this is about Donald Trump
Oy Vey now it's good to focus on your
opponent but damn this would be on
creepy it's like a cult formed around
the exorcism of a giant demon shaped
like a tweet they spent so much time
fretting about the other guy it was like
a rehearsal dinner where everyone there
talks about the bride's old boyfriend he
loomed large they felt tiny but if he
took Trump's personality out of the mix
they'd have absolutely nothing to say
nothing about his achievements on jobs
economy peace because those are pretty
good which is why they had to stick to a
game of who hates Trump more Pietschmann
must go forward I hope that he is in
Beach we have to impeach this president
began an impeachment proceedings I
support impeachment pursue this
impeachment I started the need to
impeach movement as president's
criminality and his lawlessness he has
committed crimes in plain sight a
criminal in the White House of course
CNN set the whole thing up with its
first question about impeachment no
surprise since that's Jeff Zucker's meal
ticket some reasonableness did show
through briefly if impeachment is driven
by these hyper partisan interests it
will only further divide an already
terribly divided country unfortunately
this is what we've already seen play out
as calls for impeachment really began
shortly after Trump won his election and
as unhappy as that may make us as
Democrats he won that election in 2016
that was nice but you know when you have
11 people all fixated on one adversary
suddenly they become a fraction of em
brave but small the Magnificent Seven
Dwarves almost times two their obedient
answers to CNN's direction reduced them
to bumper stickers and t-shirts not
people there were good boys and girls
reciting today's lesson which only made
the enemy more interesting everyone
talking about how one thing is like the
worst thing ever well there must be
something to that big bad thing Trump is
now right up there with punk-rock rap
music and Elvis's hips they say it's bad
for you only because they wish they had
a little bit of that mojo for themselves
Elvis's hips remember Dana that was a
big deal we weren't allowed to look at
Elvis's hips at my house oh they
actually black they blacked out Elvis's
hips I think they did maybe I dreamt
that anyway if they focus are Trump's
personality because they can't talk
about jobs or the economy notice there
was almost a zero talk of jobs last
night did it I don't even know if it
came up guaranteed jobs remember oh yeah
I already wants to get we were had a
conversation but it went in a circle
what did you ask me I don't remember now
you're my favorite weather person
they're targeting Trump because they're
running against Trump yes that's why
there you go talking about Trump Emily
say something incredibly fast okay the
attacks a identified where they all were
on the spectrum of the obsessiveness
right so we had komlin in the outset and
biden warren tait in Peacham now and
then we had that measure at approach
like you said you know Tulsi and Chloe
sure I also think though that it showed
in those that pivoted to actionable
achievable policy that's why they stood
out so that would be Klobuchar are with
opioids mayor Pete with Medicare for all
who's gonna pay for it bite into an
extent when you brought up Obamacare
that's what made them stand out and that
they use those moments to say okay but
enough of that for a second here's what
really matters including yen in that
moment that talked about the loss of
jobs in Ohio
in 2016 so what I thought was that
actually they were more focused on Crump
and earlier debates than this one kind
of died down a little bit but I
understand because I saw the montage was
pretty effective I would say that I
think the polls also it's not just them
I think they're reacting to voters
especially Democratic voters who are
clear that they want Trump and Peach in
the polls showed not only now it's like
50 percent even in a Rasmussen poll want
Trump impeached and room
so that's a pretty steep thing for any
politician to ignore especially if
you're in a Democratic Party debate the
other big news has been that Pelosi says
she is not going to have a vote on
whether or not to begin impeachment
proceedings and you have to stop and say
well why would that be because they were
president and the Republicans are saying
this is a process thing it's not fair to
the poor president and clearly Nancy
Pelosi saying she's an equal branch of
government she doesn't need his
permission have the votes to be voted on
cuz she wants to protect her own people
on it how about the point is this one
the point is this the Democrats are
looking at a nightmare scenario and
here's what there was so cover your ears
are ok ok they impeach in the house it
dies in the Senate and the whole thing
overshadows the Democrats running for
president Trump either beats a socialist
three beats of boring and broke
candidate and they retake the house so
they have the house and the Senate Ruth
Bader Ginsburg retires riah points
another justice and they pass another
round of middle-class tax cuts that is
what they're looking at and that is a
very strong possibility I see that's why
the polls are all going in this
direction on is going to be epic it is
it is that's when I run Dana
oh yes I don't know can we start that
maybe I'll run up 5k I'll start out
small all right